bienvenidos a enlace conosur en esta
emisión desde el río de janeiro-brasil
hablaremos de la inflación que está
llevando a la pobreza a una parte cada
vez más importante de los 213 millones
de brasileños daremos un repaso a las
cifras oficiales para intentar entender
que ha llevado a la subida descontrolada
de los precios y cuáles son las
consecuencias para el país más grande de
américa latina'
hoy también hablaremos de la peor sequía
de brasil en los últimos 91 años que
está dejando muchas ciudades sin agua y
también amenaza el funcionamiento de
muchas centrales hidroeléctricas
viajamos a la nueva ponche una localidad
del estado de minas gerais donde nos
encontramos con pantanos vacíos y
también hablaremos de la historia del
cristo redentor el monumento más famoso
de brasil que acaba de cumplir 90 años
en septiembre brasil registró el peor
dato inflacionario de los últimos 27
años hoy la inflación se sitúa en el 10
25 por ciento y la peor parte se la
lleva la gasolina lo vemos aquí el
precio del litro está en siete reales
126 dólares todo un récord y hay más en
los últimos nueve meses la gasolina ha
subido un 40% la subida de la gasolina
se debe a que el barril de petróleo
alcanzó el nivel más alto de los últimos
tres años ya que el dólar subió un 39
por ciento desde la llegada al poder de
jair bolsonaro
el resultado es que los alimentos que
son transportados por carretera se
encarecieron un 12% del último año dos
puntos por encima del nivel de la
inflación los productos alimenticios que
más han sufrido aumentos son los
frijoles un 70 por ciento el arroz un 60
por ciento y la carne un 30 por ciento
el precio inalcanzable de la carne ha
hecho que muchos brasileños tengan que
renunciar al churrasco del domingo el
consumo de la carne ha bajado al mismo
nivel que hace 26 años además el
85% de los brasileños reconoce que tuvo
que renunciar por lo menos a un alimento
en el último año por causa de la
inflación hemos preguntado a los
cariocas qué tal se las apañan para
llegar a fin de mes y esto es lo que nos
han contado
tenemos que apretar por aquí apretar por
ahí y economizando por otro lado dejando
de comprar muchas cosas para poder
sobrevivir
sobrevivir así una tortilla con huevo
cebolla tomate y vas improvisando es la
única forma porque todo está muy claro
las ventas han bajado bastante nadie
quiere comprar comprar lo mínimo para
poder sobrevivir y aumentó el número de
personas que piden los restos entiendes
antes de la pandemia ya venían pero eran
menos hoy hay más personas siempre
guardamos los huesos y los donamos
y
la alimentación no es el único problema
que preocupa a los brasileños el país
tropical pasa por la peor sequía de los
últimos 91 años y en el sur y sureste
del país los pantanos registran el peor
nivel de los últimos 7 años además en el
interior del estado de san paulo al
menos 17 ciudades tuvieron que limitar
el suministro de agua corriente
en el estado de minas gerais que
visitamos a principios de octubre los
pantanos están por debajo del 15 por
ciento de su capacidad
en este puente es evidente cuánto ha
bajado el nivel del agua se puede
apreciar en las marcas de sus pilares
entre los expertos hay unanimidad sobre
la causa de esta sequía histórica el
cambio climático y la deforestación de
la floresta amazónica
estoy seguro de que si no tenemos
lluvias significativas en octubre y
noviembre dentro de la media tendremos
racionamiento de energía eléctrica y
apagones a no ser que se busquen fuentes
alternativas hoy estas fuentes están más
centradas en quemar combustibles fósiles
[Música]
frente a este panorama desolador el
ayuntamiento de río de janeiro intenta
recuperar un poco de normalidad tras
casi dos años de pandemia y también el
turismo internacional recientemente se
celebraron los 90 años del cristo
redentor que es el emblema de esa ciudad
y de todo brasil la lluvia algo poco
frecuente en los últimos meses impidió
las celebraciones al pie del cristo y
todo se realizado dentro de la catedral
de río en el centro de la ciudad
en 1921 apareció el primer boceto de la
estatua llevaba una cruz en la mano
izquierda y un globo terrestre en la
derecha los cariocas lo apodaron de
cristo' de la pelota en referencia a la
nueva pasión del momento el fútbol en
1923 se hizo un crowdfunding masivo para
recaudar los fondos la obra costó unos
65 millones de dólares para la época el
proyecto final un cristo de brazos
abiertos fue desarrollado por el
ingeniero héitor da silva costa con una
altura de 38 metros sigue siendo la
estatua en estilo art decó más grande
del mundo en 2007 fue incluida entre las
siete maravillas del mundo contemporáneo
el cristo que representa el marco
superior de la fed es una referencia en
cualquier país del mundo cuando ven el
cristo se acuerdan del río de janeiro y
de brasil
janire el invento gracia entonces todo
el mundo lo dice quien viene a río de
janeiro y no a visitar el cristo no
estaba en río de janeiro es por eso que
es muy importante el cristo redentor
atrae a un millón de turistas por año y
el ayuntamiento de esta ciudad esperan
que vuelvan pronto ahora que la pandemia
está más controlada y que hay más de 100
millones de brasileños totalmente
vacunados esto ha sido enlace conosur
desde el río de janeiro brasil les
invitamos a que nos envíen sus
sugerencias sobre temas que les gustaría
ver en este programa también les invito
a que sigan con nuestra programación en
france24 en español y hasta pronto